later this afternoon you'll meet with
President Biden what are you hoping to
accomplish in the meeting and how do you
plan to convince him that Ukraine is
ready for NATO membership also beyond
the cluster Munitions that the U.S has
said it will provide Ukraine what other
military assistance are you seeking from
the in Biden Administration that have
you have not yet received and for
Secretary General general stoltenberg
how quickly do you expect NATO Nations
to be able to provide the f-16s that
president zielinski has been requesting
uh about F-16 is also to to me you
addressed to me
no no no no no no answer please
haha
okay okay so
you get you can also yes answer on all
these three questions about NATO when
when it will be and it okay